pues mira la verdad es que no quiero
aburrirte enseñándote todas las formas
que hay de sacar determinantes porque
hay muchísimas y verlas todas podría ser
aburrido pero un poquito de aburrimiento
unos 7 minutos de aburrimiento viendo
una forma más para sacar determinantes
puede ser muy útil porque esta otra
forma de sacar determinantes seguro te
la vas a encontrar en otros lados por
ejemplo en tu clase de álgebra y quiero
que sepas que esta otra forma de sacar
determinantes que vamos a ver aquí es
equivalente a la forma que vimos en
estos últimos vídeos ok se trata de la
regla de salud entonces supongamos que
tenemos una matriz de 3 por 3 vamos a
poner aquí la matriz más general de 3
por 3 o sea
b c d
h
aunque están de acuerdo que esta matriz
representa a cualquier matriz de 3 x 3
ya que todas estas letras pueden ser
cualquier número ok entonces nosotros
sabemos calcular este determinante y una
de las formas de hacerlo es escoger esta
fila podemos escoger cualquiera de estas
filas o de hecho cualquiera de estas
columnas pero bueno vamos a escoger esta
fila porque es el primer ejemplo que
vimos entonces este determinante es
igual a aquí empezamos con un mes más a
por el determinante de la sub matriz que
nos queda de quitar esta fila y esta
columna o sea
efe h
y como tenemos aquí un más entonces nos
toca un menos
por el determinante de quitamos esta
columna y esta fila y nos queda de fg y
y ahora como teníamos un menos nos toque
aún más
por el determinante de tachamos la
columna y la fila de 6 nos queda de g
h
h y ahora nada más tenemos que calcular
estos determinantes de 2 por 2 o sea que
nos queda esto es igual a a
por aquí tenemos por i
por iu - efe por h
efe por h y luego tenemos menos b por el
determinante de i
- efe
este es un ave fg efe
y finalmente más ce por el determinante
de h de h - g
todo esto lo aprendimos a hacer hace
unos cuantos vídeos y ahora vamos a
distribuir estos paréntesis estas
cantidades entonces nos queda a por él
- a efe h - v
y ahora nos queda menos por menos más
más de fg más se ve h de h
y finalmente menos c
y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es poner
primero todos los términos que se están
sumando y después todos los términos que
se están restando entonces aquí nos
queda este se está sumando este se está
sumando y este también se está sumando
ósea
más de fg más
h y ahora los términos que se están
restando o sea nos falta este término
este término y este término ok menos a
efe h - b
- sí
ok tal cual tal cual este determinante
es exactamente igual a esta fila de por
acá de términos que se suman y se restan
esta es la definición de determinante
que vimos hace unos vídeos que es
perfectamente válida en todo el mundo y
es muy útil y vamos a ver muchísimos
vídeos en los que es súper útil poder
sacar estos determinantes pero bueno
vamos a ver ahorita esta ecuación tal
cual que es lo que nos dice que y de
hecho vamos a volver a escribir nuestra
matriz
a ver nuestra matriz es la matriz a b
d efe
h
y qué es lo que tenemos aquí a ver este
término
y tal cual lo que es es la
multiplicación de estos tres términos ok
y el siguiente término bfg es la
multiplicación de estos dos términos con
este término que he dicho lo podemos
pensar así como los videojuegos de que
empezamos aquí y nos seguimos en la
diagonal pero cuando llegamos a la pared
aparecemos del otro lado y seguimos
bajando aunque hay entonces aquí tenemos
estos tres términos que se están
multiplicando y que aparecen en esta
ecuación y finalmente el último término
que se está sumando es cdh que digamos
que empezamos por acá y nos damos del
otro lado de la pared y aparecemos por
acá y seguimos bajando en esta diagonal
usted estos tres términos también se
multipliquen y los sumamos todos ok y
esta es la regla de esta ruta al cual ok
lo que hace la regla de desarrollo
es tomar la matriz a ver
d efe
h
y después para no andar diciendo que
atraviesa la pared y aparece del otro
lado lo que hace es copiar las dos
primeras columnas a la derecha de
nuestra matriz o sea aquí lo que pone es
a d
h
esta es la regla de cerros
l
a ruth que parece como sacado del libro
del señor de los anillos o algo así pero
bueno el chiste es que este término está
el cual lo que nos da debe multiplicar
los elementos de esta diagonal y este
término sale cuando multiplicamos
estaría con él
este término sale cuando multiplicamos
esta diagonal
se nos vamos de diagonal en diagonal
multiplicando términos y donde está este
término a efe h pues un ph está en esta
diagonal que además cosa curiosa la
diagonal está en sentido contrario y se
está restando eso nos dice algo no bueno
el chiste es que si la diagonal se está
inclinada hacia el otro lado
entonces los términos de esa diagonal se
tienen que restar muy bien entonces
vamos con la siguiente este término
donde se encuentra este término está en
esta diagonal
y finalmente este término donde está
pues se encuentra en la última diagonal
completa que tenemos en esta matriz y
listo ok esta regla desarrollo realmente
es nada más una digamos que mnemotecnia
para escribir todos estos términos ok ya
que tenemos nuestra matriz que le
ponemos las dos primeras columnas a la
derecha entonces lo único que tenemos
que hacer es buscar qué diagonales están
completas y cada una de esas diagonales
si las multiplicamos nos va a dar un
término de estos y además si la diagonal
está inclinada en este sentido
este término se suma y si la diagonal
está inclinada en el otro sentido este
término se resta que yo creo que
deberíamos de hacer un ejemplo con una
matriz con números de deveras
así es que pues vamos a hacerlo
entonces vamos a sacar el determinante
de la matriz
digamos 124
2 - 13
y finalmente 40 -1 que queremos sacar
este determinante entonces por la regla
desarrollos lo que tenemos que hacer es
copiar estas dos columnas aquí a la
derecha o sea que queremos aquí un 12 42
menos 10
y vamos a necesitar más espacio por
abajo
y ahora sí vamos a empezar a calcular
según las reglas de salud lo que tenemos
que hacer es tomar esta diagonal
y multiplicar estos elementos o sea que
nos queda 1 x menos uno por uno
eso es un -1 y vamos a hacer lo mismo
con todas las diagonales y vamos a sumar
lo bueno si la diagonal está hacia el
otro lado vamos a restar lo aunque
entonces de esta primera diagonal nos
quedó menos 1 entonces vamos con la
segunda con el segundo d con el 2 por 36
por 424 que entonces aquí tenemos que
sumar 24 y la última diagonal en este
sentido nos queda
4 por 2 por 0 entonces es como tenemos
un 0 multiplicando no importa qué
números eran estos aquí nos va a quedar
más 0 ok entonces ya que hicimos todas
las diagonales completas que van en este
sentido porque aquí ya no queda ninguna
otra entonces ahora sí vamos con las
diagonales que van en el otro sentido y
la primera pues es esta
entonces vamos a multiplicar 4 x menos 1
por 4 esto es menos 16 ok entonces aquí
tenemos menos 16 pero como la diagonal
está inclinada hacia el otro lado
entonces tenemos que restar esto así es
que al final de cuentas nos queda nada
más más 16 pero bueno dejamos aquí los 2
- y vamos con la siguiente diagonal ok
esta es la siguiente diagonal
y de aquí nos queda uno por tres por
cero cualquier cosa por cero es cero
entonces tenemos que restarle cero que
es lo mismo que sumarle cero pero pues
ya ni modo
y finalmente la última diagonal
aunque es 1 x 2 x 2
esto es 2 x 2 4 y tenemos que restarle y
listo
ok entonces tenemos 16 menos 4
esos son 12 de aquí tenemos 12 y de los
términos que se sumen tenemos 24 menos
123 y finalmente 12 más 23
esos son 35 y listo esa es otra forma
muy fácil de calcular determinantes de 3
por 3 y como vimos arriba es equivalente
a sacar este determinante de 3 por 3 de
la forma en la que le estábamos sacando
en los vídeos anteriores